sería una campaña de desinformación el
actual mandatario de Guatemala Alejandro
llámate y aviso esta mañana por medio de
sus redes sociales que dejará el cargo
el 14 de enero de 2024 justamente para
contrarrestar esos rumores de que
pudiera prolongar su función en el
gobierno Y es que existen motivos de
preocupación ya que dos semanas después
de la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales todavía no se han
oficializado los resultados por lo que
los dos candidatos que más votos
obtuvieron en esa primera vuelta
exigieron este domingo al tribunal
supremo electoral oficializar cuanto
antes Esos resultados Empezando por
Sandra Torres La candidata advirtió este
domingo que según ella le quieren robar
las elecciones y que existen intereses
nacionales e internacionales por una
judicialización de esas elecciones esas
declaraciones intervienen después de que
el siete de Julio la presidenta de la
Corte Suprema de Justicia
interpusiera de manera unilateral un
recurso para
suspender la oficialización de esos
resultados por su parte el segundo
candidato que más votos obtuvo en la
primera vuelta el académico de izquierda
Bernardo Arévalo no se quedó con
denuncias verbales su partido político
el movimiento semilla interpuso accionó
este domingo un recurso contra la
presidenta de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia